[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez y vamos a dar
inicio con el tema del día muerte
Cruzada en Ecuador el presidente de
Guillermo lasso disolvió El Congreso y
llamó a elecciones en el segundo día de
su juicio político ha adelantado en la
asamblea nacional por supuestamente
ignorar un presunto desfalco al estado
en un contrato de transporte de petróleo
que fue firmado antes de que él llegara
al cargo un juicio que ha estado basado
en argumentos que han sido cambiantes en
las últimas semanas y que el mandatario
califica de movida política
para dar una salida constitucional al
Ecuador
He decidido aplicar el artículo
148 de la Constitución de la república
que me otorga la Facultad de disolver la
asamblea nacional por grave crisis
política y conmoción interna además
he solicitado al consejo nacional
electoral la convocatoria
inmediata a elecciones legislativas y
presidenciales para el resto de los
respectivos periodos por supuesto la
oposición promotora del juicio político
rechazó la decisión de lasso que implica
además el final de esta legislatura
nosotros no nos aferramos a nuestros
cargos nuestros cargos Siempre han
estado a disposición del pueblo
ecuatoriano aquí existían únicamente dos
salidas democráticas la salida
democrática era que el presidente
desahuciado renuncie se vaya a su casa y
deje que el Ecuador prospere Y resurja
esa era la salida democrática que
buscábamos a través de un juicio
político absolutamente legal pero si es
que el presidente Llama a muerte Cruzada
nosotros no le rehuimos e insistimos una
vez más nuestros cargos como siempre a
disposición del pueblo ecuatoriano las
partes invitadas a esta discusión son
romel Jurado quien es analista político
y profesor de la universidad central del
Ecuador e Ismael Quintana analista y
constitucionalista Ya regreso con
nuestros invitados para las preguntas
pero antes quisiera recordarles a
nuestros televidentes que ustedes
también hacen parte de este debate dejen
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de nuestras redes sociales en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram nos encuentran como
France 24 guión bajo s con la etiqueta
numeral el debate f-24 a mí me
encuentran en Twitter Como ángel hago
f24 y por supuesto no olviden que todos
nuestros contenidos están disponibles
para ustedes en Apple podcast en Spotify
deezer y también en TuneIn
y se abre este debate porque esta fue la
segunda vez que la oposición del país
intentó remover al lazo de su cargo
desde que inició periodo en el año 2021
pero es la primera vez que en el país se
lleva a cabo el procedimiento conocido
como la muerte Cruzada siendo así Ismael
Quintana comienzo con usted está de
acuerdo con la muerte Cruzada
Bueno es un mecanismo tan válido como el
enjuiciamiento político que la asamblea
buscaba frente al presidente de la
república el presidente lo ha hecho
dentro de los tiempos que establece el
artículo 148 de nuestra Constitución
dentro de los tres primeros años de su
mandato y ha invocado una causal que
además la grave crisis política y
conmoción interna no exige
pronunciamiento previo de la corte
constitucional es una calificación que
queda a criterio personal subjetivo y
político del propio presidente de la
república Y por esa razón esa decisión
presidencial se ha hecho efectiva
inmediatamente Más allá de las
consecuencias políticas y electorales
que se producirán con unas elecciones
anticipadas tanto de parlamento como de
presidente de la república para
completar los respectivos periodos
constitucionales y sobre las que espero
tengamos la oportunidad de conversar
ahora quisiera preguntarle romel Jurado
Cuál es su opinión sobre esta decisión
inédita que ha tomado el presidente del
país
Buenas tardes Ángela buenas tardes
Ismael miren Yo coincido también con
Ismael de que esta era una vía
constitucional para resolver el grave
conflicto político que vive el Ecuador
que no ha cesado pero que implica una
vía institucional constitucional de
resolverlo si hay o no suficiente
fundamentación de la medida tomada esa
es una discusión jurídica que puede ser
planteada la corte constitucional pero
en efecto no se requería ningún control
previo de constitucionalidad para que el
presidente de la república invoque el
artículo 148 y determina la muerte
Cruzada hasta ahora me parece que se ha
procedido en derecho puede gustarnos o
no gustarnos la decisión puede ser más o
menos efectiva para resolver este
conflicto político o no pero desde mi
perspectiva se ha seguido el orden
constitucional no se ha fracturado el
estado de derecho se ha procedido de con
la ley claro lo que pasa es que extraña
mucho que se utilice por primera vez en
la historia esta medida romel Y por
supuesto que les hago esta pregunta para
iniciar el debate porque han surgido
voces denunciando que es una movida
inconstitucional que es una movida
ilegal Pero aclarando eso romel lazo
gobernará por decreto hasta que se
siente en la silla presidencial un nuevo
mandatario y ya emitió su primera orden
de que fue recortar impuestos para las
empresas y los Ecuatorianos de la clase
media esta medida fue bien recibida por
algunos empresarios Usted qué opina de
este decreto Y qué decisiones teme que
pueda tomar lazo mientras está aún en el
poder
mire hay que racionalizar estas
posibilidades lo primero que hay que
decir es que el presidente lasso no
puede tomar cualquier decisión los
decretos son finalmente normas
operativas que lo que hacen es permitir
la ejecución de lo que está establecido
en la ley es la ley la que establece los
derechos y obligaciones de los
ciudadanos Esto es lo regular hay una
excepción Sí hay una excepción el
decreto económico
urgente que es un decreto ley económico
urgente este decreto ley puede
efectivamente crear derechos o
establecer obligaciones para los
ciudadanos pero no se activa
automáticamente tiene que pasar un
control previo de constitucionalidad en
la corte y Solamente una vez que pase
entonces puede ser implementado además
hay otro control posterior la asamblea
electa puede derogar estos decretos ley
y por otro lado los decretos ordinarios
con los que cualquier jefe de estado
gobierna con los cuales cualquier
presidente de gobierno hace su función
esos ser revertidos o derogados por el
próximo presidente sin ningún problema
Entonces me parece que hay que
racionalizar esta perspectiva de que
puede gobernar efectivamente durante
seis meses Pero eso no significa que
pueda ser lo que él quiera no Claro eso
lo tenemos eso lo tenemos bien claro más
con la vía legal que usted nos está
describiendo pero para este último que
dice de que podrían ser derogados por el
próximo presidente Pues habría que
contar con que fuera un presidente de la
oposición quien se sentará en esa silla
presidencial en ese sentido entiendo por
lo que usted me dice que no le preocupa
ningún cambio que pueda hacer Guillermo
lasso dentro de las leyes que tenía
represadas y que han sido constantemente
bloqueadas al tener una minoría en la
asamblea nacional existente hasta hoy
Mire no es que no me preocupe siempre
hay cierto grado de preocupación lo que
digo es que el presidente lasso no tiene
condiciones políticas ni un marco
jurídico que le permita hacer cualquier
cosa y que se están alimentando temores
de manera exacerbada desde mi
perspectiva de que él se vuelva una
especie de dictador que aproveche esta
coyuntura para hacer cualquier cosa que
le sea posible aunque quisiera hacerlo
Me parece que eso no sucederá entre
tanto Entonces voy para el otro lado
Ismael Cuáles son esas iniciativas las
más importantes del gobierno que usted
cree que lazo debería aprobar digamos en
el término de la distancia por decreto y
y que debería aprovechar este momento
que le brinda la decisión que ha tomado
de aplicar este cierre de la asamblea y
esta convocatoria a elecciones
a ver yo creo que hay que aterrizar un
poco el tiempo que va a tener el
presidente lazo para hacer todo lo que
la gente y sus este seguidores aspiran a
que haga Ya ahora sin tener una asamblea
nacional de oposición digamos que más
menos el proceso electoral va a demorar
noventa y siete días a partir de hoy es
decir en 97 días nosotros vamos a ir a
las urnas y vamos a elegir una nueva
asamblea nacional y vamos a elegir
también un nuevo binomio presidencial
Entonces en ese estrechísimo periodo de
tiempo que son más o menos tres meses
tres meses y medio y si estuviese una
segunda vuelta electoral cuatro meses y
medio el presidente mayor cosa no va a
poder hacer por varias razones la
primera la Constitución le autoriza
entonces a emitir decretos ley en
materia económica pero como explicaba
rommel y lo hacía muy bien esos decretos
y ha ocurrido ya con este primer decreto
cuatrocientos setenta y dos que se ha
firmado unas reformas el carácter
tributario no entran a regir
inmediatamente es decir Tan pronto el
presidente suscribe el decreto sino que
pasan a un control preventivo al menos
así lo dice nuestra Constitución de la
corte constitucional más allá que la ley
de garantías jurisdiccionales que es la
ley que aplica la corte constitucional
para resolver los procesos de su
competencia Establece que ese control
sería posterior y mediante demanda de
inconstitucionalidad es una discusión
que tendrá que zanjar en todo caso la
corte constitucional Lo cierto es que
estos decretos no entran entonces en
vigencia por sí solos ahí ya vendrá la
discusión entonces de Cuál es la
limitación de lo económico urgente Habrá
gente que pretenda entonces pasar por
ejemplo reformas laborales que es un
tema pendiente del gobierno que es un
tema que no pasó la anuencia de la
legislatura que ha sido ya cesada en
funciones y habrá que ver entonces si la
corte constitucional que en este momento
se convierte en una especie fíjese usted
de legislador del presidente Guillermo
le va a dar el visto bueno para que
estas reformas tributarias laborales
aduaneras entre otros aspectos que él
quería implementar desde dos mil
veintiuno que asumió el mandato pudiesen
cristalizarse sin el perjuicio como ha
dicho rommel que la siguiente asamblea
porque no es del siguiente gobierno es
la siguiente asamblea la que pudiese
intentar en cualquier momento derogar
estos eh decretos que el presidente lazo
Quisiera poner en vigencia pero
aclarándose que para que la siguiente
asamblea derogue estos decretos leyes se
requiere de la iniciativa presidencial
porque en Ecuador la Constitución
Establece que es competencia privativa y
exclusiva del presidente de la república
presentar proyectos de ley que creen
modifiquen o supriman impuestos Así que
lo que usted preguntaba hace un momento
es bastante importante en este punto
Quién va a ser el nuevo presidente de la
república Y acaso si va a seguir la
misma línea liberal en el ámbito
económico que ha seguido el presidente
Guillermo lasso bueno Y usted cómo ve
ese panorama ya que nos lleva hasta ese
terreno
la cosa acá en Ecuador es incierta y
rommel no me dejará mentir de hecho ya
hoy han pasado apenas unas horas de la
firma del decreto de disolución
parlamentaria y acá ya empiezan a asomar
los candidatos a la presidencia de la
República
Lo cierto es que acá hay una corriente
política que es la del correísmo que
tras los resultados de las elecciones
seccionales de febrero pasado acá en
Ecuador salió bastante fortalecida
llegando a capturar alcaldías y
prefecturas en provincias y en ciudades
que antes no había tenido como es el
caso de la provincia del guayas
principalmente y la ciudad de Guayaquil
Entonces eso hace que tal vez el
movimiento del correísmo que es el que
más ha festejado la firma de este
decreto de solución parlamentaria sea
quizá la única organización política con
muchas probabilidades de obtener no solo
una nutrida mayoría en la legislatura no
sé si mayoría absoluta de setenta votos
y con altas probabilidades de al menos
poner un candidato en la segunda vuelta
electoral del resto Lamentablemente en
Ecuador los partidos políticos suelen ir
divididos en las listas de las
candidaturas a la asamblea y se suelen
presentar abundantes candidaturas a la
presidencia este de la República Así que
es un Enigma es un incógnita saber
entonces quién se proyecta como el
próximo presidente de la república pues
mire me gusta mucho que hable de este
tema Ismael porque justamente quería
traer a colación las palabras del
expresidente Rafael Correa que como
usted bien dice ya se pronunció y da dos
mensajes por un lado está el rechazo
Pero por otro lado está las
posibilidades que se podrían abrir para
su movimiento escuchemos
lo que lazo hace es ilegal obviamente no
hay ninguna conmoción interna tan solo
no pudo comprar suficientes asambleístas
para salvarse En todo caso es la gran
oportunidad para liberarnos del lazo de
su gobierno y de sus asambleístas de
alquiler y recuperar la patria fíjese lo
que le preguntaba antes sobre las
cuestiones de legalidad o ilegalidad de
esta convocatoria a la muerte Cruzada
que ha hecho lazo y pues viniendo de una
voz de autoridad de y de un ex
gobernante como es Rafael Correa
evidentemente esto puede generar
reacciones en la población pero ahora
Quiero preguntarle más por el tema
político podrá el correísmo capitalizar
este llamado de elecciones Usted cree
que este será un impulso del resultado
de los comicios regionales como
mencionaba el colega porque pues si
bienes tuvieron un buen resultado esto
No necesariamente garantiza que el
siguiente presidente que se siente en la
silla presidencial sea un correísta
mire hay que hacer un análisis de las
fuerzas en efecto la revolución
ciudadana pues alcanzó
nueve prefecturas de las 24 que hay y 55
gobiernos locales de los 220 gobiernos
locales que hay pero no solamente fueron
nueve y cincuenta y cinco sino que
fueron las más grandes del país en
términos de población que vota y en
términos de población que habita esas
regiones eso pone una fuerza electoral
potente como una especie de capital de
entrada que puede adjudicar el
movimiento de la Revolución ciudadana
también Es sobre himno un apoyo político
real para realizar una campaña ninguna
otra fuerza política tiene la estructura
de la Revolución ciudadana ni tampoco
tiene esa gran cantidad de prefecturas y
gobiernos locales eso es un factor que
hay que que incide por otro lado el
presidente Correa o el expresidente
correa ha sido el principal y más
notorio opositor de el presidente lasso
su contradictor Y entonces la figura que
tiene el presidente Correa y su
incidencia en la por lo menos en los
seguidores de la Revolución ciudadana es
tan fuerte que todos hablan de que ha
asegurado O estaría asegurado o
alrededor de un 30% de la votación que
fue más o menos la votación que el
candidato del correísmo sacó en primera
vuelta 33 me parece 34% en primera
vuelta en las elecciones anteriores
entonces son condiciones de partida que
realmente favorecen mucho al proceso de
la Revolución ciudadana Por otra parte
está también la fuerza de derecha que es
el partido social cristiano que tiene
aspiraciones también de competir Y al
menos como ha dicho Ismael poner un
candidato en la segunda vuelta si es que
la hubiera es muy probable es muy
probable que el movimiento de revolución
ciudadana sea el digamos no el
triunfador total pero el que tenga los
mejores resultados y creo que desde mi
perspectiva con las condiciones que he
señalado El que tiene más opciones de
conformar gobierno en los siguientes
seis meses Bueno lo que se está jugando
aquí es evidentemente el destino del
país Ismael regreso a ustedes Cuál es su
aspiración o su análisis de lo que
podrían ser esas candidaturas que dice
que ya se empiezan a asomar apenas dado
el anuncio de lazo para las elecciones y
Y aunado a eso Quiero preguntarle si
usted ve que habrá oportunidades para el
oficialismo dependiendo por ejemplo de
las acciones que emprenda a continuación
Guillermo lasso
a ver yo creo que el presidente lasso no
tiene capital político para aspirar a
quedarse en el en el cargo presidencial
es un presidente que y se sabía en la
primera vuelta de abril de 2021
obtuvo apenas doce escaños en la
asamblea nacional el movimiento creo que
es el movimiento del oficialismo que ha
dirigido y ha fundado Guillermo lasso es
un movimiento raquítico en la ex
asamblea nacional tanto así que tuvo que
aliarse con doce o Trece asambleístas
independientes para hacer bancada porque
con las doce curules que el presidente
lazo obtuvo no le iba a alcanzar ni
siquiera para ser bancar de tal manera
que ese Movimiento Político Yo le diría
hoy no representa al país no representa
a la centro derecha ahora
es un Movimiento Político que ha pactado
en la asamblea nacional con la izquierda
y eso es algo que al voto duro que tuvo
Guillermo lasso que era alrededor del
veinte y del 21% en esta última elección
al menos en la primera vuelta
no le ha gustado estos acuerdos como se
suele decir Perdón que sea tan tan duro
pegados con Saliva No resultaron y por
eso estamos en este escenario sumado a
que el presidente se ha dedicado a
a incumplir sus promesas de campaña
tanto así que fíjese usted que después
de dos años recién él pretende derogar
estas leyes tributarias que él mismo
puso en vigencia en el año 2000 Este
veintiuno Entonces el presidente lazo yo
no creo que tenga realmente y no creo
que este tiempo le alcance para levantar
la imagen las últimas encuestas le dan
incluso por abajo del 15% de de
credibilidad con eso difícilmente va a
alcanzar siquiera a una segunda vuelta
electoral tiene otros movimientos
políticos históricos que son de
izquierda o de Centro izquierda como es
el caso de la izquierda democrática y
del movimiento indígena pachacútec que
sin duda alguna hoy se opone al decreto
de disolución parlamentaria porque saben
y son conscientes que internamente están
tan divididos que no van a lograr
consolidar candidaturas legislativas y
presidenciales y que no van a lograr
obtener en esta siguiente elección el
mismo número de curules que obtuvieron
en la elección pasada de de 2021 habrá
que verse hay otras organizaciones
políticas también de Centro derecha como
es el caso de suma movimiento del ex
alcalde de Quito Mauricio Rodas ver qué
va a pasar con el partido social
cristiano que ha sufrido también una
crisis a raíz de este juicio político
que pues ya quedó insusistente ahí
legisladores que han abandonado esa
tienda ese habla mucho de que se le
exigiría por ejemplo a Jaime nebot el
alcalde de Guayaquil asumir Ahora sí de
nuevo una candidatura presidencial pero
sin duda alguna yo no sé si alguno de
los grandes líderes del país de
cualquier tendencia política como Jaime
nebody otros les interesará asumir una
presidencia de la República o antes de
aquello una candidatura para asumir un
gobierno que va a durar en el mejor de
los escenarios hasta el veinticuatro de
mayo de 2025 porque la Constitución no
va a renovar los periodos es decir esta
elección no es para cuatro años como
comúnmente se se produce en Ecuador sino
que es una elección que se da solamente
para completar los periodos para de los
que originalmente han sido designados
tanto Guillermo lasso con el
vicepresidente borrero como esta
asamblea que hoy se fue en funciones
Entonces es muy corto el tiempo y yo no
sé si algún político que tenga
aspiraciones más grandes quisiera
quemarse con un gobierno que va a ser
básicamente de transición bueno pero hay
que ver si se va a quemar o si esto
puede ahondar la fortaleza para una
siguiente candidatura mientras que se
construye este debate se han producido
el día de hoy ya algunas noticias se ha
pronunciado en esta tarde el Consejo
Nacional electoral algunos datos
simplemente para que estemos en lo mayor
de la actualidad antes del 24 de mayo ya
tendrían que anunciarse la fecha de
elecciones sabemos cómo hemos repetido
aquí que Guillermo lasso no tiene
impedimentos para presentarse que además
habrá un reglamento especial para esta
elección extraordinaria por llamarlo de
alguna manera y que deben garantizarse
en 90 días como esta de hecho dictado
por la norma también ese ha dicho que no
estaría contemplado una segunda vuelta
Así que tiene una decisión Express Y no
habrá inscripción de nuevos partidos
políticos con estas reglas que empieza
ya a delinear el cne que rápidamente ha
reaccionado a la decisión de lazo pues
quisiera continuar hablando con ustedes
sobre lo que bien señalaba Ismael Y es
que solamente servirán los elegidos
hasta el 2025 cuando las elecciones
volverían a su calendario habitual
Cuáles son los efectos de esto en los
legisladores y le pregunto primero a
usted romel se beneficia o se perjudica
la institucionalidad del país en su
opinión
mire aquí si voy a discrepar con Ismael
yo creo que la conformación del
siguiente gobierno a pesar del breve
periodo por el cual va a tener vigencia
es es muy muy importante porque hay
medidas urgentes que el estado
ecuatoriano requiere pero que sobre todo
el pueblo ecuatoriano requiere
presidente lasso tiene nueve mil
millones de dólares o cerca de nueve mil
millones de dólares en una reserva
monetaria en el extranjero que desde mi
perspectiva
apuntarla el pago de las obligaciones
que ha contraído con los multilaterales
los tenedores de bonos y los acreedores
del Ecuador están muy contentos de que
haya una reserva monetaria que garantice
el pago del servicio de la deuda pero
eso se ha hecho a Costa de las
desatención de los Ecuatorianos y se ha
intentado poner unos candados legales
para impedir que haya inversión Desde
esa reserva en las necesidades de los
Ecuatorianos nosotros tenemos apenas un
presupuesto de 33 mil millones poco más
de 32 mil y pico millones de dólares
entonces nueve mil millones una una
cifra importante para la economía
ecuatoriana para la sociedad ecuatoriana
el siguiente gobierno
la siguiente asamblea tendrán que
destrabar los candados legales y
canalizar Con urgencia la inversión de
esas reservas O al menos de parte de
ellas para dinamizar la economía y para
ser compensaciones sociales poderosas
eso se puede hacer en relativo corto
tiempo otro problema que nosotros
tenemos es el de la inseguridad
y se ha querido combatir la inseguridad
con una especie de securitización de
violencia del otro lado frente a la
violencia delincuencial violencia del
estado y requerimos un plan integral de
reapropiación del espacio Público de
organización de la comunidad para
defendernos de la violencia pero también
una policía y unas políticas públicas
que concurran que permitan darles
oportunidades a los más empobrecidos
buena parte las razones de la violencia
están en la ausencia de estado y Desde
esa perspectiva creo que también el
siguiente gobierno puede pues ir en esa
dirección y otro tema es el de
investigar la legitimidad del
endeudamiento externo sobre todo el
producido en el año 2020 que transformó
una deuda que se podía liquidar con
2.700 millones de dólares en el mercado
secundario en una deuda que va a 2041 y
que se ha convertido en una deuda de más
de 25.400 millones de dólares y el
estado el gobierno de lasso se ha negado
a decir Quiénes son los acreedores del
Ecuador Quiénes son los tenedores de
bonos se han negado a mostrar la
trazabilidad de esa tenencia de bonos
entonces hay cosas importantes que hacer
y si se hacen el que las haga Por
supuesto que va a tener muchas y muy
buenas condiciones como movimiento me
refiero para en el 2025 participar ahí
sí en las elecciones por un periodo de
cuatro años Bueno pues es llamativo
porque todos esos temas que usted dice
no solamente resumen las dificultades
que ha tenido la antes de que asumió en
el 2021 sino que son temas realmente
gruesos y también cabe preguntarse si en
el plazo que queda de este periodo
cualquier mandatario que asuma el poder
tendría la capacidad o el margen de
maniobra para trabajar y de eso pues
también sería aventurarnos demasiado
porque depende de cómo quede conformada
la asamblea no pienso que ambos estarán
de acuerdo conmigo en eso porque he
visto que han tenido unas intervenciones
muy prudentes no muy controladas acerca
de lo que podría pasar en términos
políticos para el país pero ahora
quisiera ir más con sus opiniones sobre
cómo queda pintado el Ecuador en este
momento Ismael comienzo con usted porque
estos acontecimientos inevitablemente
nos van a recordar la crisis que se vive
en Perú muy cerca del Ecuador y hacen
pensar en episodios también como la toma
de Brasilia a principios de este año y
como Estas supuestas ideas de que podría
estarse gestando un golpe de estado en
Colombia estos rumores que han existido
en el país entonces son meses de
convulsión o para una región que
históricamente ha estado muy
convulsionada
considera Ismael que Ecuador podría
unirse a esa a esa inestabilidad o esta
Va a ser una transición pacífica y
tranquila pues hacia una nueva
legislatura y un nuevo gobierno
Creo yo que no vamos a tener esa
convulsión que mucha gente cree el caso
ecuatoriano si dista mucho por ejemplo
de lo que ha ocurrido hace hace poco en
Perú básicamente porque en el caso
peruano el presidente decidió asumir
otras funciones que la constitución del
año noventa y tres no le entrega en el
caso ecuatoriano lo que Nosotros
llamamos muerte Cruzada no implica
asumir un proceso dictatorial vamos el
presidente lasso no ASUME el mando del
poder judicial del poder electoral del
poder de transparencia y control social
esos esas funciones Siguen trabajando
normalmente y cada una con sus
estamentos con sus instituciones y con
sus funcionarios presidente lazo seguirá
manejando El Ejecutivo ni siquiera va a
entrar a reemplazar en su totalidad al
poder este legislativo bajo esas
condiciones hoy en la tarde ha habido un
anuncio del movimiento indígena de la
conaie y han dicho que ellos al menos
por el momento no tienen preparada una
intentona de desestabilización o una ola
de protestas frente a la decisión que ha
tomado el presidente lazo lo cual en
algo alivia la situación Porque entonces
Creo yo que vamos entendiendo que este
es un mecanismo que se ha establecido en
la Constitución de 2008 elaborada por el
correísmo
y que precisamente se estableció para
zanjar esto que en los años 90 y a
inicios de los dos mil ocurrió en
Ecuador con mucha frecuencia que fue el
cese irregular de presidentes de la
república para eso está precisamente la
figura de la muerte Cruzada para zanjar
democráticamente constitucionalmente
estas crisis políticas que atraviesan
Ecuador y otros casos que usted Comenta
este a nivel regional así que yo no creo
que vaya a ocurrir eso Si es que acaso
hay protestas Espero que esas protestas
ocurran dentro del margen que la corte
constitucional acaba delimitado es decir
que no haya violencia que no haya
exacerbación y que si es que alguien
decide de la decisión del presidente se
lo haga insisto dentro del margen de la
ley de tal manera que el Ecuador como
queda bueno queda de Cara a unas
elecciones que están a la vuelta de la
esquina consejo electoral tiene siete
días para convocar a las elecciones lo
hará hasta el veinticuatro de mayo hacía
anunciado Ya ahora en una rueda de
prensa la presidente del del Consejo
electoral Y a partir de ahí corren
noventa días que van a tener que
cumplirse a raja tabla para efectos de
que en esos noventa días nosotros
podamos ir a las urnas y decidir quién
debe culminar el mandato tanto frente a
la asamblea nacional como frente a la
presidencia de la República entonces en
los siguientes días vamos a empezar a
ver acá en Ecuador ya el desfile de
precandidatos a la presidencia de la
República de precandidatos a la asamblea
nacional Ecuador entra Entonces
anticipadamente ya y extraordinariamente
también a un periodo
electoral aplicando una figura que los
académicos los opinadores pues
discutíamos mucho pero en la teoría y
que finalmente se ha terminado
convirtiendo en una realidad la muerte
Cruzada claro es que la pregunta que yo
le hacía es bastante osada en el sentido
de que es difícil comparar dos contextos
diferentes de dos países diferentes pero
pues tengo que insistir eh También con
usted porque Claro entre los opinadores
también se puede difundir esta idea de
que Ecuador podría convertirse en Perú
una vez utilizada esta herramienta y
probada su efectividad claro probado su
efectividad si se mantiene la
constitucionalidad y la
institucionalidad en el país pero
también probada su efectividad si se
llegan a a puertas cerradas nuevamente o
a situaciones de Callejón cerrado como
este
Como sucede en Perú constantemente que
cada vez que se encuentra un camino
cerrado pues existen estos cambios tan
fuertes y estos choques tan fuertes
entre El Ejecutivo y entre el
legislativo Usted qué opina
miren en principio yo coincido en que
como se ha realizado este procesamiento
constitucional de la crisis política no
hay razones ni jurídicas ni políticas
para convulsionar el país sin embargo
hay que ver cómo se desempeña en este
breve lapso el presidente lazo que tiene
unas condiciones digamos complejas la
primera es que la acusación política ha
sido saldada con la muerte Cruzada pero
la acusación judicial no tiene una
denuncia por peculado ante la fiscalía
general del estado y hay una indagación
previa abierta y me parece que en este
periodo otros actores podrían presentar
también acciones judiciales en contra el
presidente lasso por otros actos que
digamos se han ventilado en lo público
sin llegar a consolidarse antes pero que
ahora podrían motivar denuncias
judiciales desde la supuesta del
presidente en paraísos Fiscales y otras
acusaciones más
qué hay por qué se realiza esto porque
es una forma de alguna manera de decir
al presidente no atente contra derechos
no haga demasiados cambios no haga
demasiadas propuestas que puedan
violentar los derechos de las personas
que van a reaccionar de esta manera ya
sea por vías judiciales pero también por
la vía de las calles es decir lazo
tendrá que analizar si hace una retirada
silenciosa tranquila pacífica o si
quiere aprovechar este espacio de tres o
cuatro meses en que va a gobernar para
llevar a cabo ciertas propuestas que no
ha podido consolidar a lo largo de su
mandato con asamblea la conflictividad
social no solamente depende de la
oposición o de los actores de oposición
o de las organizaciones populares la
conflictividad social también depende de
la actitud que el presidente lazo asuma
en esto que podríamos llamar retirada y
estaremos por verlo tenemos ahora
entonces un mandatario saliente que
tiene menos del 20% de aprobación y en
sus declaraciones de hoy algo clave que
dijo Ese que él deseaba devolver el
poder a los Ecuatorianos para elegir
como quieren ser gobernados y de ahí
pues esta decisión es de la muerte
Cruzada y de la convocatoria de
elecciones generales Ya llegamos al
final de este debate yo les quiero pedir
a ambos su conclusión no Para dónde va
Ecuador después de este episodio Ismael
comienzo con usted y finalizamos con
romel nos quedan menos de cuatro minutos
se lo debo decir con mucha preocupación
Creo yo que el Ecuador avanza
inexorablemente hacia el retorno al
correísmo que es algo que al país le
costó mucho o de lo cual le costó mucho
salir fueron diez años de 2007 a 2017
donde el correísmo capturó el poder
donde se adueñó de las principales
instituciones del estado
donde el país quede endeudado donde
además las libertades fundamentales
fueron absolutamente atropelladas y Creo
yo que el país avance avanza hacia allá
Es decir yo no veo en el Horizonte al
menos no al día de hoy una organización
política y un líder político que pueda
asomar en este momento para hacerle
frente al correís Así que
lamentablemente Pues bueno las
cuestiones avanzarían hacia allá salvo
que mi apreciación personal esté
equivocada en la siguiente asamblea
veremos una mayoría correísta Y al menos
Creo yo que tendremos candidato
correísta
menos en segunda este vuelta electoral
habrá que ver si la derecha o la centro
derecha presenta alguna alternativa
decente y pero fíjese que dijeron que no
iba a haber segunda vuelta
el Consejo Nacional dijo que no iba a
haber segunda vuelta Es que es que no
puede no haber segunda vuelta vamos las
reglas electorales Claro que van a ser
especiales en este caso porque los
periodos de tiempo son cortos pero sin
alguien no gana porque no hay como
modificar la Constitución el quórum la
mayoría requerida para ganar la
presidencia de la República en primera
vuelta Es decir para esquivar las reglas
constitucionales de segunda vuelta
electoral están en la Constitución el
consejo electoral por la vía
reglamentaria jamás eso sería
inconstitucional podría crear nuevas
reglas electorales que vayan en contra
de la Constitución Entonces los
calendarios electorales que por supuesto
son apretados en este momento van a
tener que ajustarse a esa a esa
exigencia constitucional si usted no
tiene un binomio presidencial que
alcance la mayoría de votos requeridos
tiene que celebrarse sí o sí segunda
vuelta electoral en Ecuador
muy bien lo escuchamos para su cierre
mire vivimos los Ecuatorianos problemas
serios de inseguridad problemas serios
de acceso a la educación pública de
hecho tenemos un alto grado de
desviación escolar problemas gravísimos
de empleo problemas económicos muy
graves nuestra balanza comercial Es
favorable pero con apenas 200 millones
de dólares tenemos muy serios problemas
con respecto al mantenimiento de obras
emblemáticas relacionadas a la
producción de energía y también a la
vialidad cosas que se construyeron
efectivamente durante el período de la
Revolución ciudadana y que dieron mucho
bienestar y trabajo a muchas personas
los servicios públicos están colapsados
hay que pues recuperar la patria como
dice el eslogan de los correístas hay
que recuperarla Porque eso significa
derechos para los ciudadanos acceso a
bienes y servicios públicos y me parece
que sin duda dada la correlación de
fuerzas el movimiento de la Revolución
ciudadana muy probablemente llegue a
formar gobierno y efectivamente como
señal Ismael a tener mayoría en la
asamblea y la dirección Será esa retomar
la inversión pública y la mejora de las
condiciones de los servicios y bienes
que el estado ofrece a los ciudadanos
Espero que se haga con la mayor
prontitud y pulcritud posible y si ha
habido excesos o ha habido
arbitrariedades Pues que estas sean
evitadas a toda Costa con la vigilancia
de los ciudadanos pues viene muchas
gracias a nuestros invitados a rommel
Jurado analista político y profesores de
la universidad central del Ecuador
gracias rommel
Gracias también Ángela y el
agradecimiento también para Ismael
Quintana analista y constitucionalista a
quien nos acompañó hoy con una postura
para abrir el panorama además
gracias Ángela un abrazo a la distancia
también el agradecimiento para los
encargados de producción Andrés doncel
de la producción general de este
programa Y Tania Herrera de la
producción de nuestros invitados sigan
con nosotros ya volvemos con más
[Música]